you uh
remember that translator funny little
lad one eye
i remember the air she used to score got
you so off your tits you ran through our
bass right naked as a jay bird
no mike that was you oh
of course was it yeah cheers
so what sort of extraordinarily deep
[ __ ] are you in that you come
shuffling up to my door in the middle of
the night i thought maybe you could help
me
find her
tasty who is she it's your wife
someone married you yeah frey so
i thought maybe you could put some
feelers out you know get some of the old
intel boys
piggins a square all respect yay
doesn't seem to me like your girl wants
to be found
look are you gonna you know me or not
of course i am we're mates
are we
ordering pizza are we take it easy mate
plotters are on their way you shouldn't
have done that chuck
you topped that stillwood woman on the
telly you're gonna top your wife as well
i don't kill no one okay
hey train you're out out of what out of
seven
how many more people have to die what
are we gonna do
we're gonna sit around and cross our
fingers that homeland are gonna save us
i let my wits end i'm the face of the
seven
not you wait
i found becca bought facility arm to the
teeth
won't be easy
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my video for the boys
season 2
short movie obviously this is all about
butcher's character it's meant to fill
in that gap of time in episode
1 before he shows up but after
homelander dumps him in that parking lot
we've also got a bunch of footage from
the next couple of episodes so we'll
break it all down there's a bunch of
easter eggs if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything
obviously my episode 4 video will post
tomorrow too
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the boys so far
but just starting at the beginning of
this footage i'll talk about the short
movie stuff in the easter eggs first
then i'll talk about the trailer footage
so like i said it starts with butcher
being dumped in the parking lot of that
family restaurant a couple of states
away
just because homelander is mean like
that he literally flew him a couple
states away just to dump him in the
middle of nowhere
they have that awkward comedy of the
hostess seeing him on the news broadcast
while he's frantically writing down
details of becca's whereabouts with the
crayon on the menu
then he takes off hot wires a car and
takes it to his old squad mate's house
from the military
i can't tell if they're supposed to be
kiwis or australians based on their
dialect
but it should be clear from the way that
they talk to each other about their
history together in the picture of them
from the ward that they fought together
for australia for new zealand
either in iraq or afghanistan the boys
comic book was actually being published
while all those wars were going on 10
plus years ago so the war references
that it made were to older wars the boys
tv show because it's happening now has
just been moved up in the timeline a
little so it references more recent
conflicts
they said that they were filming this
during the first couple of episodes but
it just didn't work
inside the episode that they wanted to
put it in so they just turned it into
its own short movie by itself
but pretty much the same thing that
happened at the restaurant happens
between butcher and his former squad
mate
his squad mate hears vots fake story
being broadcast about butcher killing
stillwell which we know didn't happen on
the news
and believes it rather than believing
butcher he says it's because he saw what
butcher did during the war just implying
that he was
super hardcore when they were in the
military and because this is all
supposed to be happening before the
events of episode two and three
where butcher went crazier and crazier
on huey even threatening to kill him
if anyone else got in his way of trying
to find becca you can kind of see how
this would have helped set that up a
little bit more explaining more of
butcher's backstory and how he used to
be
really really crazy in the war there's
this whole idea that they were setting
up in the first couple of episodes about
butcher getting darker and darker his
methods getting more and more hardcore
just like homelander getting more and
more wtf it's just
the first couple of episodes homelander
was doing that with milk
getting crazier and crazier with the
milk which somehow seems even worse than
all the stuff that butcher is doing and
him
beating the crap out of the marvel
daredevil parody character and lasering
all those random people left and right
but speaking of milk mother's milk
literally has that conversation with
butcher in the tunnels during episode
three about him going too far
so it's more a question of what's gonna
happen once they do find becca
because there is footage in that episode
four trailer of becca on the street
looking like she might wind up being
reunited with butcher pretty soon or at
least they find out where she is
but moving into the footage from the
rest of the season that they have in the
trailer here it mostly focuses on hyping
the inevitable confrontation between
homelander and stormfront
in vaught's tower here but stormfront
has this rally where it seems like she
starts stoking the people's fears
trying to get the public to demand
vaught use more compound b
to create even more superheroes to
protect them from the quote-unquote
super villains that are coming to get
them
the totally fake super villains that we
know that vaught is inadvertently
creating because they were also created
with the same compound v that voc
controls
remember the whole thing here is that
the public is getting ready to turn
on vaught unless they talk real fast now
it seems like stormfront has this plan
to do that to get the public to demand
that they create more supers so it's a
good thing now suddenly that they have
compound v
but homelander doesn't know anything
about this she's playing this four
dimensional chess game that he just
doesn't totally understand
so homelanders watching this broadcast
of her thinking that she's calling him
out like he won't be able to save them
you think homeland is going to be able
to save you
as if she's calling him impotent or
something like that challenging his
supremacy
but clearly it's just her playing the
public like a fiddle in order to help
vaught
remember the whole thing in the first
couple of episodes is just revealing how
much of a degenerate she really
is she's a full-blown neo-nazi somehow
she's even worse than homelander all the
crazy stuff that we've seen him do
so it just seems like this fight between
the two of them comes to a boil before
she reveals
what she's really doing the long game
that she's really playing and it seems
like he probably winds up enjoying that
quite a bit
you have to imagine he's probably going
to be super turned on by all of her
kinks
and think about what a degenerate she is
and what kind of kinks that she has if
homelander has all these crazy milk
kinks
it also seems like homelander wants to
kick a train out of the seven and maybe
that's how he winds up in this scene
here from the trailer hanging out with
the deep in the middle of nowhere ohio
he also has that whole side plot with
starlight going on where they're both
caught in a lie
trying to hide it from the rest of the
seven and clearly on the other side of
that
homelander has had it with starlight
because of what happened in the tunnels
he doesn't trust her at all so she's
also on thin ice there's been a lot of
questions about which people within the
seven will help
turn to the boys and help them take down
the rest of the seven and bought they're
just a couple characters that could go
either way at this point including queen
maeve
they also hype up kimako versus
stormfront for the rest of the season
the way the actors talk about it the
boys and butcher are all focused on
becca getting her back and taking down
the seven and vaught for good
but kimiko clearly doesn't care about
any of that she only cares about ripping
stormfront in half for killing her
brother
and clearly does not mind trying to go
after her in broad daylight in the
middle of this crowd
so this will be interesting just going
after her while she's on national
television in a crowd full of people
then it seems like butcher finally
learns where becca is exactly but it's
not really clear if they meet up at the
end of the episode or if it's going to
happen in a future episode
because she's on cctv footage here it
seems like she's still somewhere in the
suburbs so she hasn't made it out of
this sort of compound area that she's
stuck in with her son
i'm still really fascinated to see
what's going to happen between
homelander and his son as well
because it definitely seems like he's
burned or is burning that bridge
and if there's anyone that's going to be
powerful enough to fight him it would be
his son
but clearly his son doesn't completely
know about his powers yet but just a big
reminder my episode 4 video and easter
eggs will post
on friday each of the rest of the
episodes through the finale
will air once per week each friday but
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you'll see all those videos
when i post them so no worries it seems
like most people were able to find my
episode 1 through 3 video
over the course of last week everyone
click here for that video
and then click here for my brand new
chadwick boseman black panther 2 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you